stay faithful or stay single
i'm not perfect but i'm loyal
[Music]
loyalty is rare if you find it keep it
[Music]
love and loyalty run deeper than
[Music]
blood nothing is more attractive than
loyalty
give me your loyalty and i'll give you
my trust
if you truly love someone being faithful
is easy
you can only be loyal to someone who is
loyal to you
[Laughter]
[Music]
give your loyalty to only those who
deserve it
[Music]
faithless is he who says farewell when
the road darkens
[Music]
my whole thing is loyalty loyalty over
royalty
word is bond
[Music]
a real gentleman stays loyal faithful
and true to his woman
loyalty is staying true to someone when
they're not around
[Music]
faithfulness and sincerity are the
highest virtues
[Music]
loyalty requires sacrifice
[Music]
i respect a woman who can respect me
when i'm not around
love is not maximum emotion it's maximum
commitment
you know it's official
when it's unofficial and they're still
loyal
[Music]
never push a loyal person to the point
where they no longer care
[Music]
don't make a fool of yourself by being
faithful to someone who isn't
if i'm with you i'm completely yours my
loyalty will never change
stop expecting loyalty from people who
can't even give you honesty
[Music]
i don't expect you to be perfect but i
do expect you to be loyal always
the faith to step out is worthless
without the faithfulness to stick it out
loyalty is the glue that holds a
relationship together
[Music]
a promise means everything but once it's
broken saying you're sorry means nothing
[Music]
opportunity continually tests people's
loyalty
most people fail the test
cheating is not a mistake it's a choice
loyalty is not a choice it's a
responsibility
[Music]
the saddest thing about betrayal is that
it never comes from your enemies
[Music]
love is precious
being faithful shows the weight of love
[Music]
respect and loyalty are not upgrades in
a relationship
they are a requirement
[Music]
loyalty is hard to find
trust is easy to lose
actions speak louder than words
respect is earned honesty is appreciated
trust is gained
loyalty is returned
[Music]
there's something wrong with your
character if opportunity controls your
loyalty
the only people i owe my loyalty to
are those who never made me question
theirs
[Music]
those who don't know the value of
loyalty can never appreciate the cost of
betrayal
[Music]
the strength of a family like the
strength of an army
is in its loyalty to each other
loyalty runs on sacrifices
those who cannot make sacrifices cannot
be loyal to anyone
trust respect loyalty and communication
four essential parts of a successful
relationship
she's not looking for money status or
gifts
she desires honesty loyalty
and being a priority in your life
loyalty isn't gray it's black and white
you're either loyal or you're not
loyalty is a pearl among grains of sand
and only those who understand its
meaning recognize it
the scholar does not consider gold and
jade to be as precious as loyalty and
faith
[Music]
a woman's royalty is tested when a man
has nothing
a man's loyalty is tested when he has
everything
[Music]
when it comes to relationships remaining
faithful is never an option it's a
priority
loyalty is everything
[Music]
loyalty is so rare nowadays
if someone remains loyal to you
appreciate them don't take them for
granted
don't let your loyalty become slavery
if they don't appreciate what you bring
to the table
let them eat alone
if we're dating you can have your
freedom you're not my prisoner just stay
loyal and be honest
that's all i ask
those who are faithful know only the
pleasures of love
it is the faithless who know loves
tragedies
if you cheat on someone who is willing
to do anything for you you've cheated
yourself out of true loyalty
some people aren't loyal to you they are
loyal to their need for you
once their need changes so does their
loyalty
[Music]
i'm so confused with what's real or not
you say everything with such heart but
all of a sudden your loyalty falls apart
if someone sticks by your side through
your worst times they're the ones who
deserve to be with you through your best
times
[Applause]
[Music]
remember attraction is only one part of
a relationship loyalty commitment
responsibility and maturity make up the
rest
pride attracts the girl courage
approaches the girl
wisdom gets the girl
strength puts up with the girl
loyalty keeps the girl
marriage and friendship were built on
trust and loyalty not deceit and lies
love can only be given it can never be
demanded
a relationship without trust is like a
telephone with no service
what do you do with a phone with no
service
you pretend to communicate
[Music]
everybody wants loyalty consistency and
someone who won't quit
but everybody forgets that to get that
person you have to be that person
a woman is faithful in two cases when
she believes that her man is not like
anyone else
and when she believes that all men are
the same
we have to recognize that there cannot
be relationships unless there is
commitment unless there is loyalty
unless there is love patience and
persistence
marriage teaches you loyalty forbearance
self-restraint meekness and a great many
other virtues you would not need if you
stayed single
[Music]
our relationship should be based on
trust honesty loyalty commitment
understanding and your willingness to be
there for another person when the times
get hard
i don't want the perfect relationship
perfect is impossible
i want trust honesty loyalty and love
i love imperfection
i don't want perfect i want value
[Music]
loyalty nothing tests loyalty like time
patience will show you if the bond is
real or not
[Music]
you can only hold it down for so long
for somebody who consistently lets you
down
you